a moment to savor for director ramata
tulay c as her first feature film opens
in Cairn making her the second black
woman in the festival's 76-year history
to compete for the Palm door prize but
now ayodama is the story of a
Star-Crossed couple in rural Senegal
drawing on Greek tragedies and African
folk tales sees magic realism style as
critics excited
when you see Africa especially
westerners have a very particular Vision
sometimes its picture postcard beautiful
trees or sometimes its Wars I wanted
another vision of Africa and Senegal
that's why I made a universal story a
story that can speak to everyone it's a
love story and everyone whether African
or not can identify with this story
from Sudan there's goodbye Julia set
against the independence of South Sudan
a tale of racism guilt and
Reconciliation
both films were part funded by the Doha
Film Institute who chose them from 200
submitted scripts they hope success here
will open minds we've seen over the
years how important these stories are
and we know firsthand how does it feels
when you're misrepresented and we're
trying to manage that from in the in the
Mina region but also a lot of other
regions are misrepresented and we have a
a tool to help them tell their story
speed pitching their projects to French
International fund oif these filmmakers
hope to receive some of the two million
dollars in Grants the fund gives each
year Congolese producer Emmanuel lupia's
latest project Omen was 90 funded by
outside sources
filmed with budgets that go over 600 000
Euros it's almost compulsory to find the
money outside of Africa more and more
there's a generation of African talents
were there with whatever means available
to do things audaciously with ambition
and that helps
brace of African Cinema comes as hard
after the box office success of the
woman King and black panther wakanda
forever one of the continents itself
investment from streaming services like
Netflix and Amazon are fueling local
Industries signaling a brighter future
for African Cinema Charlie Angela Al
Jazeera can